poco convencional una ciencia que va a
hablar del espacio que va a hablar
clint de las plantas y evidentemente que
va hablar del futuro porque ahí en ese
título hay una expresión de futuro
necesitamos explorar el espacio es algo
que hemos empezado a hacer pero todavía
no hacemos a fondo y que necesitamos
para explorar el espacio pues entre
otras muchas cosas necesitamos cultivar
plantas para hablar de todo esto vamos a
partir de una imagen fascinante
realmente de dos imágenes fascinantes y
dos imágenes muy provocadoras muy
atractivas una las llevan viendo los
seres humanos desde que son seres
humanos que es esta quizá
desgraciadamente ahora mismo en nuestras
generaciones la están viendo cada vez
menos es un cielo estrellado la
contaminación lumínica nos hace ver esta
imagen cada vez menos o hace que menos
personas sean capaces de ver esta imagen
esta otra nos la hacen asequible nos la
hacen factible para ver recursos
enormemente complejo si normalmente
sofisticados en la imagen de una galaxia
una imagen que no se puede ver con el
ojo humano una imagen que nos acercan
los instrumentos sofisticados
de investigación astronómica pero las
dos imágenes son atractivas y las dos
imágenes nos hablan de que desde que el
hombre el hombre desde que el ser humano
el ser humano se plantea ha mirado
arriba y se ha prendado y eso que es y
ese cielo estrellado que es y hay que
hay y ahí se podría ir y se podría salir
fuera de la tierra es decir nos hacen
estas dos imágenes plantearnos el porqué
y el para qué queremos ir al espacio ya
digo 100 hace hace muchos siglos ya los
babilonios plantearon este tipo de cosas
y empezaron a trabajar en esa dirección
construyendo estos artilugios los
seguratas mediante los que pretendían de
alguna manera evidentemente conectada
con la religión pero pretendían llegar a
interaccionar de alguna manera con
aquello la visión digamos artística la
visión imaginaria de peter bruegel el
viejo recogió el mito bíblico de la
torre de babel que en definitiva
entroncaba con todo esto hoy día resulta
que hoy día en estos días en estos
mismos días en madrid se está planteando
una exposición una exposición abierta a
todo el público que se llama marte la
conquista de un sueño la conquista de un
sueño o sea que ir a marte resulta que
es un sueño del ser humano resulta que
cuando la nave baking
a martillo en el año 1976 un gran
visionario como era rey driver y se le
ocurrió decir que hoy hemos llegado a
marte porque realmente sí que sabemos
que hay vida en marte porque la hemos
llevado a nosotros porque somos nosotros
y hace unos pocos días en el país en una
revista cultural asociada con el país
venía este titular la mejor manera de
conocer al ser humano es viajar en marte
con ray bradbury es decir que de alguna
manera el salir fuera de la tierra el
explorar el espacio es un anhelo que
está en lo más profundo del ser humano y
para ello pone al servicio de todo ello
recursos científicos que desde lo que
vamos a hablar y vamos a hablar de
biología espacial al servicio de la
exploración espacial dos formas de
biología espacial una tratando de ver si
hay fin si hay vida fuera de la tierra
si hay formas de vida fuera del planeta
tierra que da lugar a la astrobiología
otra ir nosotros decidimos
si llevar componentes de la tierra la
vida que nosotros conocemos y de la que
nosotros formamos parte
por poner específicamente al ser humano
en ambientes xetra terrestres mediante
las naves espaciales y tratar de llegar
por fin a conseguir ese sueño a
conseguir ese anhelo de colonizar
planetas o satélites distintos de la
tierra en definitiva la vida no es otra
cosa que la realización de una serie de
funciones biológicas de funciones
basadas en elementos celulares y
moleculares puestas en confrontación con
un medio ambiente y la vida se ha
desarrollado en la tierra mediante la
interacción de esos seres vivos desde
los primeros que se originaron en la
tierra por procedimientos en los que no
vamos a entrar ahora mismo pero puestos
continuamente en confrontación con un
medio ambiente el asunto es que cuando
salimos fuera del medio ambiente de la
tierra nos enfrentamos con unas
condiciones ambientales esencialmente
distintas en las que hay una serie de
factores frente a los que ni nosotros ni
los otros seres vivos de la tierra están
acostumbrados están
el más importante frente a muchos de
ellos de esos de esos factores
ambientales cuando salimos fuera de la
tierra cuando concretamente el ser
humano o seres vivos de la tierra salen
fuera de ella son capaces de protegerse
de defenderse de contrarrestarlos sea
pantalla la radiación se coloca en
ambientes hábitats con temperatura con
atmósfera con gases respirables que
hacen posible fuera de fuera de la
tierra el que la vida
suceda de una forma similar a la de la
tierra pero curiosamente hay un factor
ambiental frente al que no somos capaces
de ponernos de contrarrestarlo y ese
factor es la gravedad es decir que uno
de los grandes retos de la exploración
espacial es que los seres vivos tienen
que ser capaces de adaptarse a vivir en
un ambiente que no tiene gravedad o
tiene un vector gravedad distinto desde
la tierra ese proceso de adaptación es
el proceso de supervivencia a esas
condiciones ambientales distintas
esencialmente a la falta de ese vector
gravedad que ha condicionado fuertemente
que hay todavía
condiciona la existencia de la vida
sobre la tierra se realizan experimentos
científicos en este gran laboratorio que
hemos sido capaces de construir y que de
colocar a unos trescientos y pico
kilómetros por encima de nuestra de
nuestra tierra y que es la estación
espacial internacional esto ha sido el
resultado final de un proyecto titánico
de colaboración para la paz para mí para
para misiones pacíficas entre los
grandes países desarrollados del mundo
de europa eeuu japón rusia y canadá es
una herramienta única y sin precedentes
para poder realizar investigaciones en
ausencia de gravedad bien y bueno
nosotros en nuestro laboratorio
trabajamos con plantas pretendemos
conocer los secretos y los misterios
realmente y las los mecanismos de los de
la vida de las plantas entonces cuando
esas plantas las colocamos en la
estación internacional en la estación
espacial internacional que podemos
aprender y cómo nos podemos beneficiar
de ellas pues ahí tenemos dos objetivos
fundamentales en primer lugar hacer
posible la exploración humana del este
pero también conocer cosas nuevas sobre
la vida de las plantas y de la respuesta
a condiciones ambientales adversas que
sean aplicables posteriormente a la
agricultura terrestre el poner las
plantas en es en esas condiciones coloca
las plantas por primera vez frente a un
reto ambiental que no han conocido a lo
largo de toda la evolución en el caso en
el curso de la evolución la vida
terrestre y específicamente la vida de
las plantas se ha desarrollado en
presencia constante de ese vector
gravedad de hecho hace 400 millones de
años cuando las plantas salieron del mar
y colonizaron la tierra tuvieron que
vencer un reto importantísimo que fue
mantenerse en pie y para poderse
mantener en pie una planta tuvo que
desarrollar estructuras leñosas tuvo que
desarrollar ramas tuvo que desarrollar
estructuras que hicieron que hicieran
posible el poder vencer esa resistencia
a la gravedad porque si no es decir
la resistencia a la gravedad es un
factor absolutamente esencial desde el
punto de vista de la exploración
espacial las plantas aportan cosas que
ningún otro ser vivo puede aportar es
decir las plantas deben obligatoriamente
ser compañeras de viaje del ser humano
en las aventuras de la exploración
porque necesita la presencia de esos
sistemas de soporte vital que hagan
posible el aporte de nutrientes a la
vida humana y la remoción la eliminación
de los residuos de esa vida humana de
manera que de la misma manera que
cultivar plantas para alimentación fue
un hito esencial en la historia de la
humanidad cultivar plantas para la
exploración en el espacio será un paso
significativo está siendo ya un paso
significativo en la exploración del
universo que qué papel juega la gravedad
y qué papel juegan otros factores
ambientales en la vida de las plantas
fundamentalmente la gravedad y no solo
la gravedad sino esencialmente también
la luz juegan un papel importante en la
orientación del desarrollo y del
crecimiento de las plantas ahí tenéis un
esquema una visión global de cómo
la gravedad la presencia de la gravedad
y la presencia de la luz es capaz de
orientar y de dirigir el crecimiento de
las plantas cuando existen los dos
factores cuando existen luz y gravedad
las plantas crecen orientadas con el
tallo hacia arriba y la raíz hacia abajo
y os recuerdo que los conceptos de
arriba y abajo son conceptos que parecen
obvios que parecen triviales pero que
son esencialmente dependientes de la
existencia de un vector gravedad cuando
hay luz pero no hay gravedad
curiosamente los tallos y las raíces se
comportan de manera distinta porque los
tallos crecen hacia la luz pero las
raíces que normalmente en la tierra
crecen en el suelo crecen en ausencia de
luz no son capaces de responder a ese
estímulo que se llama estímulo foto
trópico cuando existe gravedad y no
existe luz la planta se desarrolla de
una forma muy distinta no desarrolla
estructuras verdes porque no es capaz de
realizar la fotosíntesis pero sí es
capaz de orientar por sí sola solamente
con la existencia del vector gravedad de
orientar su crecimiento y cuadro existe
'ningún y gravedad la planta no muere la
planta es capaz de sobrevivir pero la
planta se desarrolla de una forma
completamente
en el estudio de esta adaptación de las
plantas al medio espacial el primer
experimento que nosotros realizamos fue
el experimento que se denominó ruth en
la misión cervantes que en la que
participó el astronauta español pedro
duque y se realizó en el año 2003 y en
ella pretende este en este experimento
pretendemos estudiar los efectos del
ambiente espacial sobre determinadas
estructuras y funciones del núcleo de
las células mediz temáticas de las
células proliferantes de las plantas y
en ese experimento y en otros que le
siguieron posteriormente lo que
encontramos fueron importantísimas
alteraciones en procesos básicos para el
desarrollo de las plantas procesos que
ocurren en las células proliferantes de
las plantas de la raíz de las plantas y
que están esencialmente afectados en el
proceso que se llama el ciclo celular y
que la ausencia de gravedad provoca
alteraciones muy importantes que de
persistir serían capaces por sí solas de
arruinar completamente el crecimiento y
el desarrollo de la planta en cambio
experimentos posteriores que se han
realizado en estación espacial
internacional han demostrado es bueno en
lo que se ve en la fotografía que fue
difundida por las redes sociales a todo
el mundo
y es que una lechuga que desde un punto
de vista científico desde un punto de
vista botánico no es otra cosa que una
planta adulta pues fue capaz de ser
crecida fue capaz de ser desarrollada en
condiciones de ausencia de gravedad e
incluso de ser degustada con aceite de
oliva y vinagre de módena por los
astronautas que estaban en ese momento
formando parte de la tripulación de la
estación y efectivamente ellos dijeron
que la lechuga estaba rica y que la
primera ensalada espacial había sido un
gran placer de manera que si tenemos por
una parte una serie de daños importantes
a nivel celular a nivel de la expresión
génica a nivel de procesos celulares
esenciales para el desarrollo pero luego
la planta es capaz de alguna manera que
no sabemos cómo de desarrollarse hasta
un estado adulto qué es lo que sucede
pues lo que sucede es un mecanismo de
adaptación es decir la planta es capaz
de alguna manera de superar esos
problemas de estresar genes nuevos de
desarrollar cambios en sus funciones
celulares y moleculares para ser capaz
finalmente de sobreponerse a ese estrés
ambiental y finalmente adaptarse de
manera
y el conocimiento del mecanismo celular
y molecular de la adaptación de las
plantas al medio espacial es hoy uno de
los más importantes retos de la biología
espacial para solucionar ese reto entre
otras cosas nosotros hemos trabajado en
este proyecto que se ha llamado ceiling
road que se ha llevado en colaboración
entre equipos europeos en los que yo he
sido el director y equipos americanos
dirigidos por el profesor keys de la
universidad de caloría del norte este
experimento se ha realizado en la
estación espacial internacional
concretamente en el módulo columbus que
es el módulo es la contribución europea
al proyecto de la estación utilizando
determinadas instalaciones localizadas
en el se ha realizado en tres
experimentos sucesivos en tres vuelos
espaciales que se han llevado a cabo
entre 2013 y 2017 el último de ellos se
desarrolló en el pasado se concluyó el
pasado mes de julio
estos son unas imágenes de los del
desarrollo del proyecto primero la
preparación de las muestras las muestras
se prepararon realmente en este tipo de
cajitas esas cajitas son por cámaras de
cultivo donde se colocaron semillas ahí
tenéis a una investigadora de mi
laboratorio colocando ese polvito que se
ve ahí son las semillas de la planta que
se utilizó que es una planta modelo que
se llama arabidopsis thaliana que no
tiene ningún interés tercer económico
pero que es algo así como el ratón de
laboratorio en la investigación del
cáncer es decir a nosotros que un ratón
se le cura el cáncer nos importa pero lo
que se sepa de como un ratón cura el
cáncer es importantísimo para el cáncer
humano pues algo parecido ocurre aquí es
decir el rápido exista liana en cuestión
nos interesa poco pero lo que se conoce
de la arabidopsis se puede trasladar a
especies de interés agrícola pues éstas
son las cajitas de la colección de
cámaras de cultivo que se lanzó a la que
se embarcó en la nave espacial y se
lanzaron a la estación espacial
internacional en estos contenedores
experimentales
lanzamiento en las naves space ex que
son los nuevos vehículos que han
sustituido al transbordador al sat el
americano que tuvo una importancia
histórica importantísima en los primeros
estudios en los primeros en las etapas
más pioneras de la investigación
espacial se acopló a la estación se
desarrolló el experimento y finalmente
amerizó en el océano pacífico
este es el desarrollo del experimento en
la propia estación con el astronauta
manejando nuestras cámaras de cultivos y
finalmente la preservación de las
muestras en unos dispositivos ese
dispositivo se llama fix box y fue
producido por una empresa española con
lo cual incluso hubo no solamente la
ciencia española que nosotros aportamos
sino también desarrollo tecnológico
español al servicio de esto la nave
dragón finalmente amerizó fue izado a un
barco y finalmente fuimos a california
al centro james de la de la nasa a
recoger las muestras a prepararlas
de manera que pudieran luego
posteriormente ser trasladadas a nuestro
laboratorio de madrid y analizadas esas
son las plantas que han crecido en el
espacio en las cajas en la cámara
cultivo es interesante ver como con luz
blanca las plantas aparecen
perfectamente orientadas con luz blanca
pero sin gravedad
las tallos aparecen orientados pero las
raíces se desorientan y con luz roja
aparece un nuevo foto tropismo de la
raíz que es uno de los descubrimientos
nuevos que se ha realizado en este
experimento la expresión génica hemos
visto que efectivamente la luz es
efectivamente un medio de sustituir a la
gravedad como medio de adaptación de las
plantas este es un resultado de un
experimento de expresión génica en el
que se demuestra que la el patrón de
expresión génica se restaura contra la
irradiación la radiación con luz a
patrones similares a los de los
controles terrestres y este es un
resultado muy interesante que muestra
que la gravedad de marte que la hemos
conseguido artificialmente en la
estación espacial mediante una
centrífuga que rota desde una estación
espacial está en gravedad cero rota la
centrífuga nos simula la gravedad de
marte y hemos visto que el
comportamiento que la orientación de las
plántulas con la gravedad marciana es
similar a la orientación de las plantas
con la grave
a terrestre mientras que en condiciones
de microgravedad que encontramos un
verdadero caos de orientación de manera
que aquello de las patatas de sembrar
las patatas en marte que se veía en la
película puede efectivamente llegar a
ser una realidad y este es el equipo
este es el equipo mío de madrid' este es
el colega norteamericano este es un
equipo francés que colabora con nosotros
y el agradecimiento final a nuestras
agencias espaciales que han hecho
posible esta estos trabajos y
evidentemente a todos ustedes por su
amable atención gracias
[Aplausos]